This is the craziest experience
because we're doing this over Zoom.
You are not in the room with
me because of this virus
that I just heard about-
But you're in the room with me.
You know how?
How?
Oh, that's nice.
Look at that!
I wrote you a letter.
This is my letter from Conan O'Brien.
Yeah!
Who writes letters, ladies and gentlemen.
I wrote you a letter
when your book came out-
And went to it, man.
[Conan] Yeah.
It's wonderful.
I wrote you a letter and your framed it.
I framed it.
But here's the crazy thing,
it's COVID, right?
Yeah.
So, I'm doing all my own framing.
So, check out the edge on it.
It's really-
(laughing)
I did it with an X-Acto knife.
I don't think you can see it,
but it's really uneven and horrible.
Oh. That looks-
That's how all my pictures are gonna be
in the house from now on.
It looks terrible.
You know, it was funny because-
Cuomo didn't think of that.
He never thought of that.
He never envisioned it,
that people would have crooked framing.
(laughing) Wouldn't it be pompous
if I had sent you that
letter already framed.
Like, my assumption was
that it would mean that
much to you, and if-
It is gold.
Yes, if whenever I sent anybody a letter,
because it was coming from me,
I sent it framed.
What if I did that?
And that was just my thing that I did.
I think that'd be wonderful.
[Conan] Yeah, and it was like-
With a lock of your hair in it.
(laughing) Exactly.